before we get on to these things that
i've written on the board
um i noticed several of you have hit
this kind of uh
curve ball that gets thrown actually
it's on the screen now actually it's
four
uh actually there's a few of them but
the one that i was particularly
discussing just out the front here was
4h
right 4h it says um
find the acute angle theta
if this is the case sine theta equals
1.1
right and we're just having a discussion
here that i thought would be worth
actually not just us having but maybe
all of the class what's the answer
undefined what's up with that your
calculator very unhelpfully says
math error and you're like why did i pay
so much for you right
maybe not that much what's going on here
what i want you to understand is
why is it undefined why is the
calculator not actually giving you an
answer help me remember sine
sine is a ratio between which sides
opposite and hypotenuse but importantly
and this is the part that actually
if your gears are turning and if you
don't just know
how to use these things but why they
work as soon as i write
this it might click for you
why this can't have an answer right it's
not just opposite and hypotenuse it's
opposite
divided by hypotenuse the hypotenuse is
the denominator
right now in a right angle triangle and
i've got a bunch here right
the hypotenuse is not just the side
that's opposite
the right angle right it is also going
to be like
in terms of the lengths of the sides
it's the
it's the longest of the sides do you
agree with that right why is it the
longest of the sides by the way why
can't you possibly
make a side longer than the hypotenuse
have a thing about this
hmm what do you reckon
because of pythagoras okay so this is a
really good way of thinking about it if
i've got an a squared and a b
squared right then a squared plus b
squared equals
c squared if the a or the b were bigger
right then you'd have like
the b squared would be negative or
something like that doesn't make sense
okay so there's one
reasoning let me give you another one
right again i'm going to do this thing
just because so useful right
form with your two hands right form an
acute angle of some form kind right
and what i want you to imagine is and
actually do it the way
i'm doing it with your palms i guess the
heel of your palms together
i want you to imagine the tips of your
fingers there's like an imaginary third
side between these
right and here's what i want you to do
we've all made an acute angle here
yeah as you widen the angle
what happens to the side that's opposite
the angle
it gets it gets bigger right angle gets
wider
the side that's between your two tips
your fingers right it gets bigger of
course it must
and what that means is you can put your
hands in there what that means is in a
triangle
right the length of a side is this is
the whole point of trigonometry
it is proportional to the angle that's
opposite a bigger angle here
means bigger side here makes sense so
tell me in a right angle triangle
which angle has to be the biggest angle
the right angle
because you've only got 180 degrees to
play with if you've already used up 90
here
you can't get more than 90 in any of
these other angles make sense
right so therefore this is the longer
side which means that when you
do this when you do this the denominator
is always
going to be bigger than the numerator do
you agree
hypotenuse is bigger so the denominator
is bigger now to get an opposite over
hypotenuse that was 1.1
the denominator has to be smaller does
this make sense
numerator has to bigger but we know
we've just illustrated why this is
physically impossible okay
so the calculator is not just saying
math error because like i don't know or
because we told it to
it's because it's physically impossible
that's the reason behind it
all right now pick up your pens uh go
ahead and draw this diagram
for me because what i want to emphasize
to you is just how we set out these
questions we've already
done a bit of it so far i just want to
make it ultra clear
because uh like i said much with algebra
and how it's like spelling right
you don't want to be thinking hard about
this you want this to be morning coming
a fluent automatic process that you
don't have to think hard at because
you're so good at it
thank you
so we're presented with
a diagram like this is not heaps of
information in fact
the question is being nice to us in that
it provides us exactly the right amount
of information
to solve the question which is to find
the value of the pronumeral in this case
it's the angle alpha future questions
not so polite they'll give you all this
additional information you're like do i
need this
like part of the question is to see
through and work out what's relevant and
what's irrelevant
okay in this case it's a nice easy one
to find alpha
what am i going to do i need a
trigonometric ratio
which one sign fantastic how do we work
out it with sign
yeah very good i think about yeah that's
that's right i think about the angle
i've got
and i see in fact it might even be
helpful if you've got another color
there right
where is the other length in relation to
this it's opposite
right so i'm going to write opposite
over here you can identify the
hypotenuse it's always
where it is regardless of with which
angle so because you've told me that
sine is what's
going to be useful i will write sine
alpha equals and then i'm just going to
do the ratio
like we said opposite on hypotenuse so
in this case 8 on 10.
now at this point as we saw earlier we
want to use our calculator to find the
next part
so i'm going to go alpha equals right
now some people will at this point write
down don't drop this down i just want
you to see how i'm doing this
some people will write this
okay now i'm going to make a case for
you toward the end of this lesson
as to why this is not such a great thing
to write directly i can see why people
do it
but in fact this is not always the
answer and i'll explain later on
why that is the case for now what i'd
like you to do is in your calculator
that is still what you do
your sign inverse of 8 on 10. can you go
ahead
and calculate that for me and get an
answer
53 and um actually i think have i gone
off
i think it wants the nearest degree can
someone read the question disagree
fantastic
so 53.13 you said yeah yep
so dot dot dot and as we saw before if i
have to do rounding
i personally like i've been doing this
for like a million years and i still do
the next step separately
i'm going to go approximately equals i
do my rounding now
53 degrees and i'll specify the accuracy
oops that'll do okay so
really handy because you know if you
round it wrong you can still actually
get
marks for the working that you put down
which is kind of handy if they weren't
caring about rounding they were just
caring about you doing it
correctly all right now the reason i
said before
this does happen to be directly what you
get out of this right but in future like
you see how we're kind of living in
right angle triangle world
at the moment right we're going to break
out of right angle triangle world
shortly not this lesson maybe but the
important thing is
sometimes there's another angle you can
get that is the correct one
not this one but something related to
that does anyone know
what it's called i don't know like the
fact that you can sometimes get another
angle another solution out of this
um there's an ambiguity actually
involved anyone know what it's called
true bearing so it is this comes up very
very
frequently in bearings questions which
we're going to have a look at um later
this period
um because you actually get these
non-right-angled triangles you get
things like this right
you've got like a triangle here triangle
here uh sorry a compass rather
and you're trying to measure something
like like this so see how this triangle
is not
right angled anymore so if i were
measuring that
right you can actually immediately see
this cannot possibly be 53 degrees
right you might actually get the same
calculation that gives you this
why can't that be 53 degrees yeah go
ahead
yeah this is acute whereas this is
obtuse
right so sometimes the answer is if
you've got that still in your calculator
display
sometimes it's not 53.13 it's go ahead
and calculate this
it's 180 degrees minus
this answer can you go ahead and just
calculate that for me just tell me what
you get it's a hundred and
126. now you see that's a much more
reasonable answer
for what this is you're like oh it's
going to be bigger than a right angle
okay
so we call this the ambiguous case for
sine
sine is really useful but it's it's got
this kind of problem in it which is why
writing this on your next line
is a bad idea because it might not
actually be the direct answer
we're lucky here nice neat well-behaved
right angle triangles but not always the
case make sense
okay